damit kriegt
er muss heute beschäftigen wir uns mit
den betrieb der person
kannst du uns sagen was person
eigentlich bedeutet das wort personen
das leitet sich ab vom lateinischen
persona das meint ursprünglich so viel
wie die rolle die jemand einnimmt in
einem theaterstück und später hat man
dann diesen begriff übertragende
gesellschaft auf die rolle die ein
mensch in einer gesellschaft spielt
nicht mein theater spielt ok ja und mit
der zeit hat sich dann hin ausgebildet
ein gekröntes individuums des
unverwechselbaren individuums du bist
eine individuelle pension ich bin eine
individuelle personen was du dir also
auch verkoppeln und charakter zu hören
genau das hat immer mehr an bedeutung
gewonnen
diese individualität die jeder mensch
hat gut da würde ich gerne bitten ein
paar klassische theorien über personen
die über person gibt zu retten hat also
gehört beginn so mit dem anregende
person
das steht ganz am anfang der theologe
philosoph der spätantike und hat eine
serie wirkmächtige definition der person
gegeben ich lese mal vor einer ständigen
natur und teilbare substanz hat eine
natur rationale individuen fia geht also
darum dass mit versucht eine substanz
könnte man auch sagen dass ganz klar
abzugrenzen
natürlich ein vernünftiges aber es ist
nicht das einzige fünfte gewesen wie zb
auch personen und auch gott das ist ganz
interessant für diese artikel theorie
der person und dann gibt's ricos
entwicklung weiter zu tun
17 jahrhundert bei ihm finden wird die
person subjektiven selbstbewusstsein
spieler noch um ganz wichtige rolle der
identität der person erstreckt sich
nicht weiter als das bewusstsein so
lange wie wir uns erinnern können
vergangene zustimmung so lange
existieren wir als person in dem ich
nicht mehr in bestimmten zustimmt dann
reicht damit nicht identisch das video
das war schon mit den fotos genau das
problem wir können uns nicht daran ihren
als erfüllt und waren nach dieser
bewusstseins theorie vom startblock
hätten wir das problem dass wir eben
nicht mehr damit identischen anweisung
nicht daran erinnern können ein problem
und jetzt bringt zu ende ein ganz
bekanntes beispiel modernes beispiel um
das zu illustrieren was er als identität
kriterium für die person versteht das
sagt tiere nehmen wir an die wählerinnen
mussten das bewusstsein des vergangenen
lebens das ist witzig wird trete in den
körper eines schuhs platz 1 und bisher
zunehmen sobald er im eigenen ferien
verlassen hätte jeder sieht ein dass der
schutz bekannten dieselbe person sein
würde wie der fürst und nur für diese
taten verantwortlich
bewusst sein dass weniger als die
identität der person im gleis über die
zeitung denkt und was auch die bedingung
der möglichkeit zur moralischen
zurechenbarkeit und verantwortung ja in
verberg verantwortung und kann durch
meine theorie dann gäb im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert eine ganz prominente theorie
vom katastrophen große analytische
philosophie hat folgendes gesagt
computer der person mit dem begriff der
person meine ich den begriff eines typs
von entitäten gaa dass ein und denselben
individuum von diesem einen typ sowohl
büros bestimmt als auch körperliche
schafften eine physikalische situation
zu weiter zugeschrieben werden können
also person ist sondern ein individuum
was sowohl körperliche als auch
psychologische prädikate gleiche maß
haben können dass die theorie vom die
testphasen und nimmt ansonsten
jahrhundert hat ein weiterer analytische
philosophie mit dem namen henry kämpfen
diese ansicht kritisiert vom des tors
was unter philosophie gelingt als
analyse des begriffs verkettung
angesehen wird ist in wirklichkeit gar
keine analyse dieses begriffs chancen
dessen wort gebraucht von gängigen
standard geworden ist bestimmt im
begriff eine person als zitat inbegriff
eines trips von entitäten theater sowohl
prädikat die bewusstseinszustände
zuschreibe als auch kreditkarten bleiben
sprechen von einfluss individuum dieses
besonderen typ gleichermaßen annehmbar
sind jetzt kritisiert diese ansichten
der sagt ich fahre vor und gibt es
jedoch neben personen auch viele andere
identitäten die sowohl mental wie
physisch eigenschaften haben zum
beispiel tiere im tierheim auch mental
auf die noch keine personen nach dem
landläufigen gilt dass wir wie kommen
wir einem autobus vielleicht tiere leben
können sich auch personen
er fährt fort auch wenn es merkwürdig
scheinen mag
aber es ist nun einmal so dass es kein
gebräuchliches englisches rhetorisches
wort für die art von entitäten gibt
diese trafen sich denkt entitäten zudem
tausende menschen genauso auch tiere
verschiedene niedrige abend gehört du
schlecht werde diese umstellung
natürlich nicht gemüse taucht eines
wichtigen und wertvollen philosophischen
terms was macht jetzt frankfurt um die
also genauer zu definieren sich zu
allgemeinen diskurs getan hast du als
kloster träger von körperlich momentan
eigenschaften frank luck sagt eher wenig
über seine person zu person macht die
mobile restrukturierungsplans okay
jetzt zu diesem wege sagt bin der
ansicht dass ein wesentliche
unterschiedlichen personen und anderen
kreaturen struktur des willens eine
person zu finden ist menschen sind nicht
die einzigen die wünsche motive haben
oder die wähler entscheidung treffen sie
unterscheiden sich darin nicht von
mitglieder anderer arten von dem einige
anstalten zucker erwägungen anstellen
und entscheidung nach vorhergehende und
bewegung treffen kommt es scheint aber
eine besondere eigentümlichkeit von
menschen zu zeigen dass sie wichtig
nennen werde die zweite stufe zu bild
und fähig sind
also geht nicht darum dass irgendwelchen
centern zum antrieb in uns haben das
aber auch tiere der gast entscheidet
person ist da wenig dass ihre wünsche
und willens den gänsen zweiter ordnung
haben jemand hat ein wunsch zweiter
sprüche wenn er entweder einfach
einbinden möchten oder bestimmte wunsch
sein will bei diesem zweiten fall
wichtig wünsche der zweiten stufe
koalition muss weiter schrumpfen
unglaublich das ist für das personen
seien wesentlich ist produktion zweiter
stufe und nicht ganz allgemein
widersprüche zu haben
es ist logisch möglich genau
unwahrscheinlich dass er behandelt
obwohl die zweite stufe aber keine
koalition der zweiten stufe hat ein
solches leben deren beiden augen keine
person gesagt was nicht mit person ist
aus einem triebhaften london - auf
englisch bezeichnet jemanden der wünsche
ihres zu stufe hat aber deshalb keine
person ist weil er gleichgültig ob er
wünsche der zweiten stufe sieht keine
koalition sei den wählern betrifft ein
reflexiven willen dieses vorher
vorangehen die bildung tendenzen zu
ok beispiel wäre zum beispiel ich möchte
nicht mehr rauchen wieder das bedürfnis
zu rauchen hat längere zeit gebraucht
dann sagt man ich möchte nicht mehr
diesen wunsch haben alle geräte und die
verpflichtende und farben zu holen das
wäre eine position zweiter stufe 1 das
wäre eine position zwei stufen das
material pensionen aus sozusagen eine
kurze clips gegeben hat theorien aber
eigentlich sehr früh schon mit dem
bewusstsein angefangen und die tendenz
das bewusstsein einfach nochmal
spezifizieren genauso wert erhält direkt
anderen der theorie und zum block genau
ist kein klappt dann aber diese fußball
ist in biel endlich verstehen ein
produktion alles bewusstsein nicht nur
theoretisches bewusstsein sondern
praktisch das macht vielen dank nun zu
den problemen der theorien kannst du da
sagen genau es gibt mehrere theorien zum
beispiel der party der effektivität
das ist gar nicht mehr darauf ankommt ob
wir individuelle person fühlt
er bringt ein beispiel wir könnten zum
beispiel und freunde teilen
bisher erwiesen dass gerne helfen die
funktion der anderen hälfte übernehmen
können wir können uns jetzt vorstellen
dass mein gehirn zum beispiel geteilt
wird und einen anderen körper verkraften
was hätten wir denn dann hätten wir auch
mir zwei personen gemacht weil jörg
haider kino mährische identität das was
eine person machte ihre individualität
wäre natürlich verloren gegangen so an
diesem beispiel setzt der reka fit ist
kommt eigentlich gar nicht darauf an ob
ihren einen gefährdet sind
die identität ist nicht das was
zentraler faktor ok soll die relation
der person ihr schwächer gestiegen und
damit eine er würde nach ihm gehen das
wenig bewegung ist in denen wir nicht
nur sehr hohen qualitäten die wir zu
behaupten betrachten
sein werk die belange von anderen
gebieten oder wie sind die eben auch
nicht ganz klar
qualität haben auf so eine theorie
ergeben sich immer auch praktische
konsequenz werden
danke schön für das erklären zur letzten
frage könnte es auch nicht menschliche
personen geben ja ganz einfach zum
beispiel das hingegen durch durchschauen
kann man sämtliche der beispiel
irgendwann fragen wie den appell eine
postiert heute aber sehr interessante
fragen etwas machen oder rené krebs
frage landes gestellt hätten wir ansätze
dazu die diese teams haben wir auch als
eine person anzuführen
gibt man kann darüber streiten das gibt
manchmal diese merkmale die typisch
bekannten filmen sprachen typisches
typische fall zudem die andere
lebensformen entdecken würden die
sozialstruktur ausbilden die ihren
anderen mitgliedern helfen wenn die in
not sind und handy und ein system haben
kommen viele hinweise darauf tatsächlich
auch sein
von trier tiere irgendwann entdecken
gibt personelle geschaffen haben es gebe
ja schon am anfang fiel es gibt sie die
ecke warten ob wir denn viel mehr als um
die extreme kälte tiere sind weil sie
die sozial form traktieren
okay das war über den begriff der person
bis nächstes mal